[Music]
mark is in peoria hi mark welcome to the
ramsey show
thanks for taking a call dave sure
what's up
hey uh i'm 60. my wife's 65
i uh
five years i'd like to be retired or
semi-retired
i have no pension no 401
no
so-called retirement fund but i have
accumulated and that's my business uh
we've got 32 rental properties and i'm
in the process
of selling them a month ago i sold
well one of my last ones i sold i took
that money paid the last three mortgages
off
uh a week ago
uh close on another one
so i've got about 70 000 sitting in the
bank and
um i've always been confident in the
properties that i've gotten i know the
business but
i would like to start buying mutual
funds and i'm out of my comfort zone
and i guess i'm terrified to
you know i've watched uh american greed
over the years and you've always talked
about smart vester pros that you have
but uh that being said um i'm out of my
comfort zone and
um i'm a little skeptical or scared of
starting to put the money in mutual
funds
wow how much these 32 houses so far
what'd you get you should have more than
700
well no no well i mean
we live i'm in the midwest
midwestern part of the country all right
i tell you what you hang on we're
talking with mark in peoria illinois he
just sold 32 rentals thinking of putting
the money into mutual funds but he knows
real estate at 65 years old is
comfortable with that and is scared
about mutual funds is that a fair
summary what you told me so far
yes i i haven't sold 32 i have 32. oh i
misunderstood the last few i've sold
been in the 60 to 70 000 range okay
they're
nice small well maintained bungalows or
ranchers usually
so why are you making the decision to
get out of the real estate business and
into the mutual fund business
well uh
i'm tired of it there's with 32
properties there's a lot of maintenance
i'm a one
one man show i pretty much do everything
i've had a
one person help me throughout the years
and right now i haven't been able to
get anybody to help me in the last six
or nine months there's just nobody out
there that will
i can hire
so you've got 32 individual single
family homes
yeah a couple couple
two three you know a couple of duplexes
and three units mixed in there but
majority of them are single family
houses what's the total value of the
whole portfolio
uh which is just about everything uh
including my house that i live in is
about 2.1 million good for you well done
well done well thank you well i'm not
sure that uh if i were in your shoes i
would make the leap to 100 mutual funds
from 100 real estate what i would
consider is some different kinds of real
estate
you're in the highest hassle factor type
of real estate um and uh if you're if
you're gonna i don't you're talking
about selling the entire portfolio off
right
well yeah i'm thinking three quarters
okay
really slow down i might consider buying
a commercial property that's income
producing whether it be an office
building
or something that has a lot less
maintenance issue
and a lot less hassle with the cl with
the uh tenant issue
the number of times i mean i've got i've
got several of both and the number of
times i get a call from a commercial
building versus we get a call i don't
get a call but our our team does our
real estate team does
versus the number of times we get a call
off a single family home is
i mean commercials just about a tenth of
the hassle and so you could take
you know three quarters of these you
know 20 of these houses
25 of these houses and convert them into
a different kind of real estate if you
wanted to
uh if you don't want to it's okay as far
as mutual funds go it's just like real
estate the first time you bought a piece
of real estate you didn't know what you
were doing it was scary
all right the more you did that real
easy the more you did it the more you
became familiar with it the more you
studied it the more you knew the
neighborhoods the more confident you
became in real estate because of your
knowledge level
and so mutual funds are going to be the
same way click on smart vester at
ramseysolutions.com get with the
smartvestor pro they have the heart of a
teacher that's why we use that
measure
as one of the ways we vet them whether
we will endorse them or not
they have to have the heart of a teacher
because i don't want people putting
money in something they don't understand
because you are always scared then so
you need to begin the process of
learning a whole new type of investing
and
just work on it and just learn
and you can wade in you don't have to go
all in at one time there's nothing
driving this except you're just tired of
fooling with rental property yeah and
hopefully i don't know that his income
if all these rentals are producing that
income but if you get rid of three
quarters of your rentals that might be
three quarters of your income so just be
thinking about that if it's tied up in
mutual funds well mutual funds you can
pull the income off yeah i mean you can
you can income it can produce you you
put two million dollars or million
dollars in mutual funds it should
produce a hundred thousand bucks throw
it ten twelve percent yeah you know you
don't have to leave the growth in there
you can pull it off so he can live off
of the income there just as well but the
truth is the real estate is going to
make more money than mutual funds but it
does have a higher hassle factor it has
more you know more to do and you've got
to get out of the business of doing the
maintenance yourself that's just not a
good long-term plan that just steals
your joy it just you know when you start
out it's like kind of cool because i got
a hammer on my belt and all this but
yeah real quick that crap gets old i
know how to do it all but i'm not doing
it all